so I'll just start by giving a quick
outline about what the presentation will
discuss today so overall I'll be
discussing - which is one of plot Lee's
newer products and - is a pythonic
framework for building analytic web
applications so first I'll go through a
introduction - - and then I'm going to
go through a few of our sample
applications so you can start to see
what's possible and then finally we'll
go through a quick demo and actually
look at the code that you would use to
write your application so just before I
get started with - some of you may be
familiar with plotly so I'm going to
quickly just described the plotly
ecosystem so first we have plotly j/s
which is our open sourced j/s charting
library so that's built on top of d3 and
stack GL and then we have a few api's as
well like our python orange julia api is
so this is basically so data scientists
can continue their visualizations in the
language that they're using for the
analysis as well and then we have charts
studio which is an online platform and
this includes a graphical user interface
so if you're not quite coding or you
just want to use an interface to create
the charts we have that option online
and then finally we've built - which is
like I mentioned before the framework
for building web applications so kind of
like the API is the idea here is that
Python users can continue doing their
analysis their visualizations and then
finally the full interactive web
application all in
Python so before we move on to the
applications I just have a chart a few
charts here so you can kind of see the
different charts that you can create
with plotly so all the charts are
interactive so we have hover click and
drag to zoom capabilities and then also
interactive legends so you can click to
remove the traces there and resize yep
so just just to get an idea we also have
annotations animations so that's just
animating a heatmap there to look at
different sections of a brain and then
some of our our newer chart types as
well with additional interactivity there
so that kind of gives super quick
glimpse into the charting aspect of
plotly and so now I'll move on to
actually discussing - and the
application framework so what is - I've
done this presentation in it so you're
looking at it and it's just a productive
framework for building web applications
all in Python we wrote this on top of
flask and plotly j/s as well as react
j/s so basically made pythonic wrappers
around react j/s components and like I
mentioned before this is ideal for
Python data scientists who want to build
a very customized user interface all in
Python
and so we'll go through but basically
it's going to be a just a few simple
patterns and that will allow you to
create callbacks and add that
interactivity into your applications and
hopefully you'll find the syntax pretty
simple and easy to get started with as
well and all of these apps are going to
be rendered in a web browser and this is
really nice because it inherently makes
your applications cross-platform and
then mobile ready as well and easy to
share because you'll be able to send
that to your colleague send your
application to your colleagues via a URL
rather than trying to bundle up the code
and making sure it's compatible to run
on their system as well yep
so to get started with - of embedded the
the documentation which is a - app as
well inside this presentation
application and I'm just gonna quickly
go through the install part so you'd be
able to get up and running if you're
interested in creating some applications
of your own so all of the packages are
on pip and basically you'd install - -
HTML components and then - core
components as well we also have a few
additional repositories such as the -
table which I'm going to be discussing
in one of the sample applications and
that's one of our newer very involved
components that we released at the end
of last year
yeah so after you get those packages
installed you'd be able to start with
the layout portion so if we just pop
over there for a second and check out
- layouts so to create a layout you'd
basically put together a few of the HTML
components so all in your Python file
you'd be adding headers divs whatever
you want to organize the layout of your
application there so for example here
we'll set up the app layout and we'll
set that as an HTML dot div function so
that's just importing the - HTML
components HTML and then using HTML dot
our headers our divs etc to build that
up and then we've imported the - core
components package to add those core
components and so if you want to add
dropdowns graphs etc you'll be adding
those to your layout as well so for
example inside my layout here I have a
header a div with some text and then a
dash core component graph which this
will create the figure which will then
render the plotly j/s graph that you're
adding there okay
okay so yep you can check out that
documentation at - plot oli and I'll
have a few helpful links at the end of
the presentation as well so you can get
started with those so now moving on to
the the fun part we have the adding the
interactivity so after we've set up the
layout we'll be able to add the
callbacks to our application in order to
add the interactivity to allow your
users to make selections in your
applicant application and render
different elements based on those
selections so for example we have our
layout here where I've added a drop-down
that you can see and then as well as an
HTML div so I can have an output
container to display some text so now to
add the interactivity I'll use our
callbacks so we'll use this callback
decorator so here in the decorator
syntax we're going to pass through our
output argument and then as well as our
input arguments so at this time each
callback can only have one single output
so you'll just pass through one output
and then you can pass through multiple
inputs so the inputs will be added in an
array to allow for multiple inputs if
you'd like so in the output we have the
first argument is the ID of what I want
to update so here I have my HTML div
that I'm updating and I have the ID set
so I'll match that in my callback as
output container and what do I want to
update of the output container I want to
update the children there
then I have my input which is my
drop-down which I've ID'd as my
drop-down and then what do I want to use
is the input I want to use the value
returned in the drop down there and then
I just have my function of what I want
to happen in this callback so I'm using
the value that I'm getting from the
input and then I just want to return a
formatted string where I'm formatting
that value so here you can see when I
make a selection it will update my text
here with the value of what I'm
selecting in the drop-down okay so like
I mentioned earlier we're passing
through those inputs as an array because
we can have multiple inputs in a
function so here we actually have a
little more complicated example where I
have a drop-down that will then update
the second selection there
and finally the text will get updated as
well so to do this my layouts pretty
similar but I'll have three callbacks
now so first all update um the city's
drop-down which would be these radio
buttons here then collect the selection
that I'm making there and finally the
string below will get updated with both
the value from the country drop-down and
then the value from the city selection
as well
great so the previous examples we're
using the the core components like
dropdowns or radio buttons to add that
interactivity into the application but
we can also use the interactive graphing
elements from those plotly jas graphs in
the application as well to create some
drill down throughout the application so
this I'm going to zoom out so we can
kind of see it all on one one page there
but this example looks a little boring
but it's actually my favorite - example
that we have because it outlines how to
use the interactive graphing function
really well so like I mentioned before
we have some hovering interaction so
here in this application when I hover on
the points we can see below what's
actually returned from that hover
interaction and same with clicking on
the points so when I click I get the
points returned below so yep right now I
have compare hover selected but if I go
to just show closest instead of
returning the array of both traces it's
going to return just the single point
there same with hovering so if we take a
look down here we get to see the curve
or trace number that's been selected as
well as the point number point index and
then we get that X&Y information back as
well then we also have the zoom
interactivity so you can zoom and get
those ranges returned as well as know if
just Auto range is set there so then
you'll be able to use this information
to further update another chart or a
table or anything you want
in order to to create drill-down
throughout your application okay so
after you've kind of built the skeleton
there of your application we do allow
style customization full style
customization and so you can do this via
CFS and so we'll provide a recommended
CSS style sheet that you can add just to
get started and that's hosted on code
pen and embedded it here just so you can
kind of see a bit of the suggested style
that we've added and what some of those
elements would look like but we also
allow inline CSS as well as the ability
for you to add your own style sheet so
you'll be able to get that fully
customized as well so here's just a
quick example of if we were creating our
layout here and we just want to update
the color background color a border or
something like that we'd be able in our
Python file just to pass through this
style dictionary directly there so we
never have to leave the Python file and
we get the style customized all in the
application so that's a pretty simple
example but if you want to get really
customized you can add a CSS style sheet
that you've created yourself in order to
get all of those updates set for you
okay
yep so you see me back in so you guys
can see that great so we have our
documentation at plot ly we have the
core github repo at github calm / plotly
/ - - - HTML components - core
components those are all open source so
you can go on github and see all of the
source code there for all of those
repositories and then we also have a
super active community forum as well
where there's a lot of good questions
and some examples as well of community
use a lot of different - applications so
now I'm going to just go through leave
the presentation and go through a few
different examples of applications so so
you guys can see a few different use
cases yep
so this is one of my favorite
applications to demo because we get to
use a super-fun image of ponies wearing
sweaters so there we've created this
application and it's going to display a
bit of image processing so I've uploaded
my favorite image here and then I
believe this is just using the pillow
package and we're going to apply a few
filters on the image and then we can see
just how the RGB values there will
differ when these filters are apply so
applied so yeah if I just maybe if I
sharpen and then enhance the contrast
quite a bit we can then see how the
graph gets updated after those colors
are changed if it based on the image
processing there so yep this apps hosted
online we also have all the source code
online too if you check out the gallery
in our Docs you'd be able to access this
and play around with it with your own
images as well
okay moving on now we have the data
table applications so like I mentioned
earlier we released in November an
updated version of an updated beta
version of our - data table component
and so that component lives in its own
repository and yep you can it's also
open source so you can check out all the
code for that so we worked on this for a
pretty long time in order to add sorting
and filtering functionality to the table
and some of that filtering syntax is
subject to change but that's all
explained in the github repository as
well as our documentation for this yep
so there's you not only have the ability
to download the CSV the table is also
editable and selectable so you can
select regions there copy and paste back
and forth between Excel or Google sheets
or whatever other hopefully whatever
other spreadsheet you're using there and
then you can also make selections here
and in this example we're making
selections and then updating the charts
below to highlight the countries that
are selected there as well as sorting
and filtering will also get applied to
the charts as well and then this is a
pretty big data set so I've added the
paging option as well so we're not
overwhelmed
the start seeing all of the options at
once once in the table that wouldn't
make for a very functional application
yep so next this is a pretty nice
example that was created by a member of
our community so it allows you to make
selections there based on your own
family history and then you can kind of
see the annotations move around so you
can kind of apply your own family
history to how to this climate change
plot here
okay so um next this example kind of
furthers how to do the graph drill down
so in addition to making selections on
the slider we have the option here of
making a selection on the map which will
then in turn update the the graph that
we're looking at update the bar plot can
then also if we want to look at
different trends that should update as
well
[Music]
the histogram
Oh
so just another example of being able to
apply grafts drill down throughout the
application as well as having other
elements that the user can select to
further explore the data set okay one of
the new functionalities that we've been
working on pretty recently is the
ability to create PDF exports and
snapshots of a of your application and
then these can also be scheduled so if
you have data that's live streaming and
updating you'll be able to schedule kind
of a snapshot so you can kind of keep
track of the different updates there yep
so when we create the snapshot it then
gets saved into our archive and we'll be
able to see not only a web version of it
so the will have the interactive web
version of the snapshot but we're also
going to be saving a PDF option as well
and then like I mentioned we have all of
that stored in our archive so you'll be
able to go back and check and access
previous previous reports and previous
data as well and I think I just have one
more one more example yeah so then this
example just is to showcase the
different hover events so as we're
hovering on the graph you'll notice the
drug representation to the right of the
graph is updating as well and then we
have the drop down if we want to store
some of those in a list below okay so
that provides pretty much an overview of
a lot of the capabilities
and different kind of applications that
you can build with - and finally I just
wanted to look at the code for a simple
example so we can kind of go through and
see exactly what the code entails
okay so this example is just over a
hundred lines of code from start to
finish there and this creates this
example where we have a drop-down to
select different countries of that
Gapminder data set and then well as well
as a slider to kind of scroll through
the years there so we're using the
packages that I Allman mentioned earlier
as well as pandas setting up the app
zoom in a little more then appending the
CSS file and that's referencing that a
CSS file that I mentioned earlier that's
hosted on code pen and then just
importing the data and creating a unique
list of the continent and years in that
data and then going through my app
layout which again is just going to be a
combination of those HTML components and
core components in order to create the
layout of the application I want and in
this I've put all the styling and that's
outside of that CSS file like all the
styling all the custom styling that I
wanted to add to the application I've
just added in line there you can see the
background color of that header element
that I have and changing the text color
in there
yep and then finally we just have a few
callbacks below where I'm able to update
the graph based on the drop down and
slider values there so then my update
date graph function is just typical
Python syntax where I'm then kind of
going through seeing what my selection
is filtering the data frame and then
updating my figure in order to display
the different traces there so that's
going to append the data trace to the
plot Li figure and then also I'm just
defining a few layout elements of the
plot Li figure that I want to define
such as the the title that's updated by
the slider value and then some of the
AXI styling as well yep and then we just
have to define the app server and that's
pretty much it so we get that
application in 103 lines of Python code
great so yep that's pretty much it so
I'll just take any questions if there
are any question
[Applause]
thank you for the talk um I have two
questions the first one is where your
favorite picture was taken
[Music]
yeah yeah good the second is how's the
the - has any connectors to disturb
systems like spark or Impala and hosta
performance when you use mysterious
systems yeah so for data connection
crunch yeah so since it's a Python
package you can use any Python
connection any Python libraries that
have been used to create that connection
so I think there's like PI spark or or
something like that I'm not sure if
Impala has a python connector I haven't
I haven't used that but yeah any sequel
connection or anything like that that
you're using in your Python code and
functionality anyway should be able to
get apply to your application not quite
but we do have an update component that
will allow that to happen so in in the
examples I've showed I wasn't using that
update component but I do have an
example that I'd be happy to show you
that uses so it's a - core component DCC
update and you can set the interval and
that will allow your apps you refresh or
certain elements of your app to refresh
and yep specifically if you want to
update your data or kind of show a live
streaming that allows that to happen yep
anyone else
so if somebody writes an application
that expects some user data and the user
uploads much more data than was expected
is - able to smartly understand that
this interactive component can't handle
that or maybe in the plotly renderer not
to try to plot a bajillion data points
at once or can just - handle that for me
on its own yeah we don't have an a
built-in functionality to do that so
that would kind of be up to the up to
the app creator to the app developer to
be able to set any limitations there or
yeah clearly explain what the what the
upload intention is but yeah we wouldn't
have any inherent behavior that would
limit what limit uploads to the
application directly good question
you only once twice so I noticed pricing
for the server how what is that do for
potential customer rather than just kind
of hosting my apps myself yeah so yep
like I mentioned so the packages I've
talked about today are open source so
you can get started using those
automatically we have our - deployment
server which we recommend for
enterprises especially if you have
specific security functionality that you
need implemented so what that adds
beyond you like deploying to Heroku or
something is our auth packages and our
application privacy settings so we have
different options where we can integrate
that with your ad or LDAP systems and
then allow you to share applications
with specific groups specific
individuals and different things like
that set the privacy to be completely
private public to your your company and
whoever has access to your server or the
specific sharing options and then we've
also started building out a bit of
functionality so like the report and
snapshotting an example that i showed
quickly that would integrate with on
your server for example so you have the
everything stored on databases on your
server basically so there's a few
different added added functionalities
like those that would ya just allow you
to get deployed up and running i'm
sharing
a little bit faster than if you were
building out that that functionality
yourself in your application so got a
couple minutes so don't be shy
all right so thank you Chelsea
[Applause]